this was the catalyst last night jazz
chisholm for the marlins swinging away
in the first pitch at ground ball to
short maria's got a hurry not in time
jazz chisholm beats out a routine ground
ball to short that's how this game
starts
this is game changing speed at the top
of the order is see chisholm wasting no
time at all jumping on the first pitch
and maybe a little too
casual for aureus and now hauser will
have to work out of the stretch and
manage
a base stealer and go after this hitter
miguel rojas got one right there with
jazz chisholm see if he tries to take
off he had two stolen bases in the first
inning there he goes it's a strike throw
to second
not in time jazz chisholm off and
running early
boy and he went in the back pretty hard
there he's got the oven mitt he hit the
ground
and pretty
much stuck there as you take a look boom
just stuck hooked around
the leg of pablo reyes
and the marlins trainer went out for a
minute to check on chisholm he seems
like he's okay
maybe caught the bottom part of reyes
spike on the hand as he was bringing it
towards the bag
oh two coming back
fister into right
garcia's there this should be deep
enough to score chisholm indeed it's one
nothing miami and a sac fly by jesus
aguilar
manufactured there
by miami
just a tough game sometimes in there
around the dirt runner goes throw from
narvaez on the bag in time what a throw
from omar narvaez
a little quicker to the plate there than
in the first inning with chisholm going
and
nice job of reyes dropping that tag
right down
on dickerson for the out not an easy
pitch to throw in either ball in the
dirt
put it in the only spot where rey is all
he had to do was catch it
got his strikeout rate lowest in the
majors 1.8 strikeouts per nine so there
castano records his first and perhaps
only one of the night if the numbers are
consistent yeah
deep center did he get enough duvall
back
adrian hauser a pitcher bomb then oh man
noise at the end and adrian hauser helps
himself
solo shot ties up the ball game
now he's got to try and amp himself down
a little bit he's got to worry about
pitching next half inning
he's he's thinking about his next at bat
who's on the top step over there the
dugout lorenzo kane
fired up his teammate
[Applause]
oh two to taylor
that's the deep center
back to back for the brewers
oh the scoreboard for tyron taylor
well it's monday night the marlins
making a lot of noise late with the bats
but here the brew crew as they take the
lead
taylor was taking some big cuts against
castano this time up and out of the zone
had to stay tall on that back side
went up the elevator to get the fastball
not overpowering from castano
it takes longer to get through the
injured players than it does the scores
and there's 15 of them usually on most
nights
aguilar sends one in the air right
center field long way back he's done it
again another home run for jesus aguilar
it up here in the fourth
the big guy back in his old stomping
grounds
a beautiful swing from the big guys the
slider that didn't slide stayed up maybe
dropped a little bit but
aguilar's eyes they don't lie right down
the barrel great extension
and plenty of distance
if anybody knows this field it's jesus
aguila
brewer's trying to move jackie bradley
uh junior around
action in the marlins bullpen
there's a base hit tonight for pablo
reyes
jbj puts on the brakes late at second
base he was thinking third but dickerson
got to the ball quickly
this one he gets down that's a beauty
leone throws the first
don't take the average of the exit
velocities on his last two at-bats
that's a perfect sacrifice bunk for
adrian hauser gets it done
and now it's time to
pick these guys up
ground ball right to the shortstop rojas
thought about home instead gets the sure
out at first brewers take the lead on
the rbi ground up by tyrone taylor
owen one endeavors
that one gets away
and birdie is going to score easily
so that's how the marlins tie it in the
fifth
how about that
i wasn't sure if jose had gotten clipped
there was
certainly
a double hit
circle change he yanks it pulls it in
jose got out of the way oh that's what
it is you got the glove
and you've got the home plate umpire
you know narvaez unable to hold on to
the
sinking changeup
showed those
flashes his rookie year in 2019 hit
above
315 hit a bunch of home runs
this one to right
long run cooper not gonna get there it's
gonna be on the warning track extra
bases casting hero watch him run
he's on his way to third and he's there
standing
that's where the over shift in the
outfield really came back to bite the
miami marlins
stand up triple casting hero
i'm sure some excitement there and hiro
he didn't hit it as well as he would
like but he hit it in the right spot and
then it's off to the races i know i've
got to double easily
how easy can i make this triple oh they
kept the uniform clean didn't have to
slide now just 90 feet away
um
putting the brewers on top
he's got to think about covering black
to black which is not easy to do
fly ball right field cooper back it's
over his head up against the wall
ureas delivers
that's the swing
that got him the home run in san diego
up and out went the other way with it
you can see the power potential from
maria's too even going the other way
base hit off the bottom of the
the bat this one flipped into shadow
right that is down for a base hit race
around third he's going to score taylor
trying for two he's going to get caught
in a rundown tagged out by miguel rojas
but ray has scored him plenty of time on
the run scoring single by tyrone taylor
and a good decision by garrett cooper
who had no play at the plate
and come up and cut off tyrone taylor
but again taylor producing
and a big spot to
put another run on the scoreboard
suitor's the guy you want to get to you
really don't want to mess with them
remember this
oh and birdie may have gotten a memo
this is a deep shot out towards center
and that is gone a home run for john
bernie the marlins inch closer on the
first pitch in the inning
only win in san francisco and here
two-run deficit
a long home run to straight away center
field and tapping into some of that
power on this trip and making the most
of the added playing time
2-2
swing he went ball game over
josh hader secures the win for the crew
they even the series with a 5-4 victory
over miami
well a nice job tonight by the brewers
after being shut out
by trevor rogers and company last night
get another home win
and pull to within one game of being 500
here but a great job by adrian hauser
pitching and then also swing in the back
tyrone taylor was right in the middle of
everything it seemed like tonight